the nation's top pediatricians group is
pushing for a recall of a popular baby
product linked to dozens of reported
deaths Consumer Reports says that
fisher-price rock and play sleeper is
tied to the deaths of at least 32 babies
now this includes infants who rolled
over and suffocated while in the seat
the American Academy of Pediatrics urges
parents to stop using this product
immediately Jan Crawford shows us how
the concerns grew Jan good morning -
this is scary stuff
it really is Gale and sad I mean this
fisher-price rocker like this one it's
advertised to help baby sleep and it
includes the phrase all night long but
the company says parents should stop
using the product once a baby is able to
roll over because if that happens they
can suffocate but that is a risk some
parents say is not clear enough and this
product they say is too dangerous to be
on the market he was the best thing that
ever happened to us
Ezra Overton was the pride and joy of
parents Evan in Keenan I just felt like
my purpose finally just came to me like
oh this is what life is for
in December 2017 Keenan says he placed
Ezra in a fisher-price
rock and placed sleeper at bedtime when
Kenan awoke he says he found his
five-month-old son facedown and
unresponsive I picked him up and he was
like a doll he's he was he was hard and
his face was blue and his nose was
pushed in the couple say they called 911
CPR before arriving at the hospital I
didn't want to believe it at that moment
for the last time Azra died three days
before Christmas
his parents blame Fisher Price they're
supposed to be about safety that wasn't
the case Fisher Price says the rock can
placed sleeper meets all applicable
safety standards and adds it is
essential that the product warnings and
instructions are always followed those
warnings which are also sewn onto the
device include a suffocation hazard and
an advisory to stop using the product
once an infant can roll over last week
fisher-price
shoot an alert with the US Consumer
Product Safety Commission reducing the
recommended age limit from about five
months to three we do not believe that
is adequate we do reports Rachel
Pietschmann says the magazine found
deaths linked to the sleeper of babies
younger than three months it's a risk
for babies of any age there is no
circumstance where this is a safe
environment for babies to sleep the
Overton's say they want to help other
parents avoid a tragedy like theirs when
you think about Ezra now how do you
think of him I think of him as a
superhero baby superhero baby we we
think about all the time I just knew
that he was meant for some big purpose I
think of him as being the stopping point
to having this product out there so he's
gonna save a lot more babies and
families this type of devastation
well the Overton say they had no reason
to suspect the rock and placed sleeper
was dangerous they've got it as a
hand-me-down from a neighbor the
American Academy of Pediatrics
recommends that babies sleep on firm
flat surfaces Anthony exactly this is
just heartbreaking
it is jann before you go I know we keep
talking about fisher-price but other
companies make this little this little
rocking thing does this recall do you
think apply to all of them or is there
something specific with the fisher-price
this has been specifically and the
recalls are recommended by the American
Academy of Pediatrics has been specific
to fisher-price but the Pediatrics
organization just also says that parents
really shouldn't use any of these kind
of devices because the baby should be
kept flat and not with all this padding
around them because if they turn over
you know it could could suffocate them
so I think it's a broad warning but the
proposed recall is pretty specific to
this one company originally I would so
so feel for the Overton's they did
nothing wrong nothing freaking about it
and hopefully this is a good reminder
and will save people's lives
all right Jen thanks